[Musique]
le président des états-unis a
maintenant
annoncé que nous retournions sur la
lune
mais nous ne répétons pas apollo nous
allons aller sur la lune
pour rester
[musique]
nous sommes reçus par des antennes de dragon
autour de l'extérieur
du vaisseau spatial
[Musique]
5.00 [
Musique
] donc [Musique]
honnêtement,
donc
nous honorons que nous allons utiliser
les ressources de la lune pour apprendre
à vivre et à travailler
pendant de longues périodes, puis
en fin de compte, nous allons prendre
ce que nous construisons ce que nous comprenons
les technologies les capacités l'
architecture et autant que possible
nous construisons l'architecture pour qu'elle soit
reproductible
à mars
[Music]
vous